– Selma!
– Hallo, Nico. Was ist denn los?
Ich musste bei meinen Eltern schon wieder
einen Sprachkurs vorschieben.
– Das tut mir leid.
– Sie werden sehr wütend, wenn sie
herausfinden, wo ich wirklich bin.
– Ich bin froh, dass du trotzdem
gekommen bist.
– Ich freu mich auch, dich zu sehen.
– Einen Moment! Nicht bewegen!
Alles Gute zum Geburtstag!
– Mein Gott!
– Ich hatte das Gefühl,
du kannst es brauchen.
– Ich bin so glücklich!
So ein schönes Fahrrad!
Ist das wirklich für mich?
– Mhm.
Das Fahrrad ist toll!
Und wenn meine Eltern fragen,
woher ich es habe?
– Wenn deine Eltern fragen,
woher du es hast,
dann sag einfach,
es ist von Lisa.
– Aber wenn meine Eltern sich bei ihr
für das Fahrrad bedanken,
dann wird sie sich doch wundern.
– Lisa weiß Bescheid.
– Das ist fantastisch!
Und heute Nachmittag darf ich
eislaufen gehen. Das wird so cool!
– Dein Vater hat das erlaubt?
– Das ist der beste Geburtstag seit Langem!